[Music]
[Applause]
channing frye
turner sports nba analyst he won a nba
title
2016 with the cavs over golden state
and uh channing kind enough to join us
all right so we know the
best team you played on what's the worst
team you played on
that's a great question maybe my rookie
year the 2005 knicks
we had the highest uh salary in the nba
and i think we won 23 games that year
with uh larry brown that was a i mean a
dumpster fire it was hilarious
what's it like showing up knowing you're
gonna lose
oh it wasn't that we were just gonna
lose because i've been on teams that
were just too young
that we didn't get it but it was still
fun but it was just like
larry we had the most starting lineups
in the history of the nba
and so you didn't know if you were gonna
start or not
until 40 minutes on the clock so he
would tell the starting lineup
and the vets i didn't get it at that
time and now
i probably do what they did it's like
just blow up they would literally
he would write down who's going start
without telling anybody
all day long it was it was pretty
amazing
now that i'm retired and now i'm not in
the nba anymore but you have these fan
bases you had that with the knicks but
you're also with the lakers prior to
lebron getting there
yeah those fan bases when they turn on
you
like oh it's not fun which one was
tougher though the knicks or the lakers
oh the next not even close the next fan
base is
the toughest we i was getting booed at a
applebee's
i'm like i'm just here for the endless
ribling basket
i'm kidding oh damn man
you know
if you were going to explain steph curry
to somebody who had never
seen him play oh man
i would say imagine a guy that could
show up on any court
and probably not be picked first but
that will never leave the court
because he's going to win every single
game like he's
he's not big he's not extremely fast
he's not extremely athletic but yet he's
too numbered one or two depending on how
old you are the most influential people
person in nba in the last
10 20 years oh probably even more than
that i
i think he's more influential from the
playing
aspect then jordan then jordan i mean
jordan
you know that that shadow's a big shadow
but steph gave hope to
anybody who steps on the basketball
player when steph had success
you said oh man i could shoot from if i
could just
steph's greatest superpower is a skill
right like steph is like iron man like
he built himself like he
worked on that and he has his innate
ability
and he like shooting is something that
everyone can do
yet he does it so well we're used to his
audacious numbers that no one
what he's doing is so ridiculous like
he's doing james harden numbers without
james harden's i mean people
underestimate how good of a score james
harden is
he's doing james harden numbers without
james harden
one-on-ones because he's coming off pin
downs he's coming off screens
like it it's amazing this year and i'm
you know what i'm i'm just gonna sound
wild i'm
not glad that clay got hurt but i'm glad
that people get to see this steph curry
yeah
i don't know if we would ever have seen
this steph curry
and i was you know i said something at
the beginning of the year that warriors
fans got mad i said
if he doesn't take this team to the he's
accomplished everything
and if he doesn't take this team to the
playoffs just the playoffs that would
dis
that would make me disappointed because
i know how good he is
and he's far exceeded that to now you
have to put him
top 15 all time as a player
what's it like when you get switched out
on him did you ever get switched out on
him
yeah oh yeah oh yeah it's the worst
because
the problem is he'll just throw the ball
to draymond and then you have to chase
him
and it's not like he's gonna just james
harden you or he's not going to kyrie
you
he's like oh you're my switch throw the
ball to someone else
you don't you can't practice that you
can't practice verse
going over these screens you can't stay
on the body he's too fast he's too
he's too smart and they set great
screens and it's just like he's
impossible to guard
because he's okay without the ball and
the minute you turn your head
he's gone would you want to be a
teammate of russell westbrook's
me as a shooter yes oh yeah oh yeah
well he doesn't he might not throw it
out to you
as often as you think you're going to
get it there channing i mean don't
listen
i i definitely think that russell
westbrook
has gotten a lot better at creating
opportunities for
other people especially on this wizard
scene um
i think his triple doubles do equate to
winning but i also feel like
any great player you lean yourself
towards their style of basketball
right it just you can't like steph can't
go to new york and be
get 50 a game nobody's getting 50 on new
york even
you know julius randle is having a great
year but i don't know what his career
high is this year
maybe 35 it's just a system so his
system that works is
fast-paced uh you know you got to score
in the 120s 130s
is he the second best point guard of all
time
who is rush no well scotty brooks said
that he's
maybe of course scott brooke said that
okay i respect that but no
we not stop it that's so disrespectful
to
either magic johnson isaiah thomas magic
is one
magic is one isaiah's two magic is and i
had this conversation last night with
one of my old teammates
magic is probably the last small guard
to win
multiple championships truly small guard
that was your
point guard right and you mean isaac
yeah
i said isaiah oh yeah you had magic
because yeah i saw
magic one isaiah two and then
you know depending on how you view the
point guard
position then maybe
man well is steph curry a point guard
i don't i don't i don't to me i think
draymond is their point guard
to me okay is is russell
would you rather have john stockton or
russell westbrook oh
john stockton stop
[Laughter]
that hurt that hurt me saying it but i
heard me saying
paulie let's bring in steve nash now
steve you just heard
no i wouldn't do that to you oh man
i wouldn't do that to you all right so
lakers warriors look like they're on a
collision course here in that
play-in tournament i don't think they're
worried about it
the languages are like we're worried
about that i don't think the lakers are
worried about it and i don't think
the warriors are worried about it
because i don't think the grizzlies or
the spurs match up very well versus
warriors right i think
the la if we are just to end the season
right now i think that's how it would
end
the lakers will be seven i think they
love that matchup versus sons
especially with a healthy lebron and a
healthy schroeder
and then i think the warriors are like i
think we have a chance versus utah
i think the warriors stylistically are
utah's
bane in utah's existence they switch
screen and roll and so there are three
things and that's what i was
talking about on tv the other day there
are three things team can do you can
play one-on-one
you can run your system or you can do
screen and roll right
and utah is the best screen and role and
system team in mba
so they pass they move they cut all that
happens because
teams can't switch but the warriors are
the best switching team in nba
so they switch underneath the last game
you watched rudy gobert had 10 points
but like
his 10 points were just i'm just bigger
than everybody 10 points
he had no impact on the game pretty much
why do you think jordan clarkson had to
go 101 so much
jordan clarkson shooting 33 shots is
exactly what the warriors want to do
right but the problem is when you add
mike conley and you add
donovan mitchell now you have more ball
handlers
but neither one of those guys so you
would have donovan mitchell and
jordan clarkson really are your
one-on-one guys
and you would say i'll take my chances
with draymond
wiggins kelly ubray and the jordan pool
kent basemore
with those chances now i think utah
would win
that series but i think utah or i think
golden state will give them a run for
their money
if i gave you the nets and the lakers of
the rest of the field to win the
championship
man uh first of all i can't bet against
braun
in the playoffs i think he's two he's
too
yeah he's got to be healthy like and a.d
is going to be
that's huge and but i'll tell you this
listen if i made as much money as he was
i'm pretty sure he's pretty healthy if i
know him
this dude gets 24 hours around the clock
and this is not a joke 24-hour
around-the-clock care every time he has
an injury
so for him they didn't have a long break
a lot of guys are coming back and
they're having soft tissue injuries
so you've seen a lot of hamstring you're
seeing a lot of you know
this year has been a weird year for them
to be seventh
i don't think the lakers give a crap as
much as everyone makes this
have you been to lebron's house me his
old house in uh cleveland
oh oh she haven't been invited to the la
crib no no i haven't it's been coveted i
haven't gone to la
i'm gonna go to his house i'm gonna raid
his wine fridge
i'll go right to the fridge what what
was the uh mansion in
was it akron yeah accurate what did it
have
in that that i would be surprised at
i mean have you ever been to a hilton
house looks like you're like hold on
hey listen where do i check it they got
a concierge there
oh for sure listen we in everybody in
nba you should take care of yourself you
get a big house i have a big house in
portland oregon
my house looks like a shack compared to
his house
i said damn i said it's what it's like
to be a billionaire
what in the f okay best best house you
were ever in
best school grand hill easily
whoa grant hill lives in orlando florida
he has like a 25 000 square foot house
and it is like i think obama stays there
when they go to
stuff in orlando he says iowa worth the
golf course
yeah he has like a tennis court oh look
you know you got a tennis court a poo
he got a a wine room he don't even be
drinking wine like that
he got expensive wines in there i'm like
you don't even drink wine
he got a couch in his couches kitchen
like what who had a club in their house
did you ever go to somebody who had a
club
uh never a cl uh maybe vince carter who
has
an equally as big house in the same
neighborhood
in iowa so it's like vince carter grant
hill and shaq
all live in the same neighborhood in
orlando vince may have had a club in his
house his house looks like
a house mc hammer would own but but
shaq's crib it i think he's selling it
but that is
that that's an amazing yeah all in one
neighborhood
all in one neighborhood all in isleworth
and i ended up renting a house there in
orlando it was
it was the best thing about orlando
other than that it was trash
i don't know why q rich and vince and
all them love it i'm just like ugh
yeah florida
uh and i just see that shaq bed that had
the big s the superman on it
yeah listen like who's gonna buy shaq's
house
because everything's to his size isn't
it somebody's gonna buy it like the
toilet
the toilet's got to be to his size right
oh boy
it must be some dinosaur-sized toilet
shack is a big guy man shaq like i'm
seven
foot however many pounds and shaq makes
me look tiny and i'm a big man
and shaq makes me look tiny i remember
had a garden but i thought that yao ming
made shaq look a little more normal
yao's head is so big yao's head
is so big right i remember i was on the
portland trailblazers
and uh you know i really i was playing
on and off with nate mcmillan
because you know the marcus aldridge was
balling and in the playoffs they like
put me in on shack or not shot but yeah
when i was i looked at the coach like
what am i gonna do with that like what
am i gonna do with this
and i'm seven foot and he just turns
around and shoots a jumper over me
and i look at the [ __ ] like that's like
that that's the best i got like
he outweighs me by a hundred pounds he
is five inches taller than me
and like he shoots the free throws for
his team he shoots the technical free
throws like
so his skill set is super high it's not
like i can rattle him
you know so i'm just here to annoy him
and you know do whatever he's got a head
that's the size of a microwave
like it's but he's the biggest guy i've
ever
mark eaton was a big guy yeah i've seen
him
but i think shaq's or i mean yao's legs
were like tables tabletops they were
so big you couldn't move him i was just
like
pushing up against the wall
i was yelling at my trainer like we need
to get in the weight room this summer
creatine great appearance uh hope you're
doing well there with uh with turner and
uh we appreciate having you on no
awesome this is great man thank you
thank you chen that's uh channing fry
that's good that's fun